sie verlangt
entschuldigen sie
die schwedische zollbeamte in china hat
ein besonderes talent man könnte sie als
eine schülerin bezeichnen sie bemerkt
dass zum beispiel wenn jemand alkohol
schmuggelt sie bemerkte etwas für die
leute zum beispiel mythen sind sie
bemerkt wenn leute eine chance mit sich
herumtragen
als sie bemerkt auch wenn die leute
scham empfinden was es mit dieser
begabung auf sich hat was dieses
geheimnis ist das thema mit sich
herumträgt das ist das thema des
schwedischen films border von ali abbas
i einem aus dem iran gebürtige regisseur
der aber schon lange in skandinavien
lebt und arbeitet
china ist ein wesen von besonderer art
das merkt man relativ früh das erste was
einem auffällt ist dass man sie wohl
auch wenn man höflich sein möchte als
hässlich bezeichnen müsste aber dieser
hässlichkeit eignet noch etwas
besonderes denn es ist eine ein anderes
aussehen könnte man sagen dass man schon
fast als nicht mehr ganz menschlich
bezeichnen würde
und tatsächlich ist auch so dass sie in
dem film dann wenn man sie sieht wie sie
sich konzentriert und wie sie versucht
die leute an der zollkontrolle zu spüren
dass sie da manchmal etwas animalisches
bekommt sie nimmt witterung auf wie ein
hund könnte man sagen man 2002 ein
bisschen daran was es genau wie die auf
sich hat dann erzählt der film
allerdings durchaus alltägliche dinge
von ihr mit einem wort das wirkt alles
ganz normal
aber sobald kinder mit sich alleine ist
sobald sie die schuhe auszieht sowie
socken auf sie und barfuß in den wald
geht merkt man dass hier eine ganz
eigene persönlichkeit ist das geheimnis
dieser figur wird gelüftet in der
konfrontation mit einer figur die dann
auch eben durch den zoll kommt
ein mann bei dem sie zum ersten mal
offen sich zu entscheiden
denn dieser freude hat eben nichts zu
verbergen oder jedenfalls nichts wofür
man ihn in gewahrsam nehmen könnte
im verlauf der weiteren geschichte
erzählt border so etwas wie eine
selbstfindung von tina die viele mit
dieser figur vorher zu tun hat und
gleichzeitige parallele eine
kriminalhandlung entwickelt schritt für
schritt kommen wir mit border in eine
mythologie hinein die mit sagen motiven
zu tun hatte wester probiert
die beiden hauptdarsteller eva melander
und aluminium norf wird man vielleicht
nicht kennen ist und tatsächlich ist es
auch so dass man sie nach diesem film in
anderen filmen nicht zu schnell oder
nicht zu leicht wiedererkennen würde
denn sie sind doch beide sehr stark
durch die maskenbildner verändert worden
das ist sehr sehr gut gelungen beide
sind außergewöhnlich physisch präsent
machen sehr gut deutlich in welchen
zwangslagen sie sich befinden und sie
sind auch sehr interessant einander sehr
nahe
auch durch das äußerliche und
gleichzeitig bilden so etwas wie zwei
pole auf einer in einem spektrum
menschlicher oder trans menschlicher
oder grenzen menschlicher möglichkeiten
der film oder fragt sich dann im grunde
sehr konsequent oder auch sehr
grundsätzlich was das heißt ein mensch
zu sein oder vielleicht eben nicht im
vollen sinne ein mensch zu sein und
welche abstufungen lässt da auch gibt
das ein wunderschöner ort